[Music]
I define intelligence simply as how good
something is at accomplishing complex
goals so human intelligence today is
very different from machine intelligence
today in multiple ways first of all
machine intelligence in the past used to
be just in always inferior to human
intelligence gradually machine
intelligence got better than human
intelligence in certain very very narrow
areas like multiplying numbers fast like
pocket calculators or remembering large
amounts of data are really fast what
we're seeing now is that machine
intelligence is spreading out a little
bit from those narrow peaks and getting
a bit broader we still have nothing with
as broad as human intelligence you know
where a human child can learn base to
get pretty good and almost any goal but
you have systems now for example that
can learn to play a whole swath of
different kinds of computer games or to
learn to drive a car and in pretty
varied environment and where things are
obviously going in the eye is increased
breaths and the holy grail of AI
research is to build a machine that is
as broad as human intelligence can get
good at anything and once that's
happened it's very likely it's not just
gonna be as broad as human but also
better than humans at all that the tasks
as opposed to some right now I have to
confess them quite the computer nerd
myself I wrote some computer games back
in high school in college and more
recently I've been doing a lot of deep
learning research with my lab at MIT so
something that really blew me away and
like whoa was when when I first saw this
google deepmind system that learned to
play computer games from scratch you had
this artificial simulated neural
networks it didn't know what a computer
game was it didn't know what a computer
was it didn't know what a screen was you
just fed in numbers that represented the
different colors on the screen
and told it that it could output
different numbers which correspond to
the different keystrokes it also didn't
know anything about and then kept just
feeding it the score and all this offer
I knew was to try to randomly do stuff
that would maximize that score so you
say well I remember watching this on the
screen once when demis hassabis
the CEO of google deepmind shodhan and
seeing the first half this thing really
played total BS strategy and lost all
the time gradually got better and better
and then it got better than I was and
then after a while it figured out this
crazy strategy in breakout where you're
supposed to bounce the ball off of a
brick wall where it would keep aiming
for the upper-left corner until it
punched a hole through there and got the
ball bouncing around in the back and
just racked up crazy many points whoa
that's intelligent and the guys who
programmed this didn't even know about
that strategy because they hadn't played
that game very much this is a simple
example of how machine intelligence can
surpass the intelligence of its creator
much in the same way as a human child
can end up becoming more intelligent
than its parents if educated well and
this is just tiny little computers sort
of hardware you can have on your desktop
if you now imagine scaling up to the
biggest computer facilities we have in
the world and you give us a couple of
more decades of algorithm development I
think it's very plausible that we can
make machines that can not just learn to
play computer games better than us but
the can view life is a game and do
everything better than us
[Music]